joining us now with reaction to
President Trump in the gops big tax
victory is counselor to the president
Kellyanne Conway
good evening Kellyanne I deem it it was
an exciting day at the White House it
has been indeed there's a buoyancy and
the vibrancy you saw it there on full
display you saw the president really
calling out by name the leaders in the
House and Senate the chairman of the
different committees and really the
rank-and-file Republicans unfortunately
they were in there Democrats there
because none of them took an opportunity
to give tax cuts and relief to our job
creators to middle-class families and
they're going to have to go home this
Christmas and all next year and explain
why they insisted this was the tax cut
for the rich one just today you had
major companies say they're going to
give bonuses and other charitable
contributions to their employees are
those employees receiving those
hard-working men and women the rich so I
think the Democrats missed a huge
opportunity here was president Trump's
leadership that really put this over the
top family and work everything see me
ask you something you know when when I
heard that AT&T was going to give
bonuses something like $1,000 to two
hundred thousand three thousand how did
the Democrats spin that this is a bad
thing and how long is it going to take
for people to recognize that this tax
cut tax reform is indeed what the
president and his supporters have said
it is indeed I think they'll see it
right away and somebody at the podium
today was making a very good point that
there are a couple of dates for
Americans to look at Janine one is
January 1st starting next year literally
we'll have a different kind of tax code
that we all live under in February many
Americans will start to see their
increase that increases in their pay
their paychecks will get fatter under
this paycheck president and in April of
course April 15th a day many Americans
dread they'll they will recognize that
many of them will simplify the way they
file the taxes they'll still take back
so much of those wasted hours and wasted
money then they'll start to see many of
these businesses repatriate the
trillions of dollars that is parked
legally offshore we're going from the
offshoring model
to the American model and it will make
our job craters more competitive I think
today was a real turning point in terms
of showing that the Congress and the
presidency can work together president
can work together to deliver for the
American people this was not a campaign
promise this is a moral imperative for
people who deserve to keep more of their
money and you you know what is sometimes
overlooked in this whole thing is that
the repeal of the individual mandate
with the requirement that people who
don't buy insurance are going to be fine
by all of those additional higher ease
at the IRS and and I assume that they
won't be there much longer you know is
is something that is a it's a good thing
so today was really three bills in one
and it was quite historic on every level
the tax cuts themselves are historic as
the president noted but having the
repeal of the Obamacare mandate also
means that another signature piece of
the Trump agenda that helps propel him
to victory over Hillary Clinton has all
but been fulfilled that the Democrats
who took the chance on the Obamacare
mandate in insisting that the individual
mandate would attract the young and
healthy to the exchanges it did not do
that the young and healthy were too
smart they weren't they were going to do
it and the whole thing collapses you
know 30 million Americans Jeannine don't
have health care as we speak the
insurers all fled the exchanges it
became prohibited for them and the third
thing in this three for one was Anwar
this has taken 40 years for a president
and a Congress to pass what others
including President Reagan and President
president's bushes tried to do which is
start drilling responsibly so that we
are more energy dependent on America we
create those jobs right we tap those
resources I mean some of the estimates
are truly incredible but all of this put
together America is going to see almost
immediately what a difference there is
in the economy and let's face it Jim the
tax cuts is the centerpiece of what's
been regular notable black energy
independence and really great a booming
stock market for the entire year he's
been president well and you know what's
interesting is they say that you know
that the booming stock market is you
know it's not even reflecting the
confidency okay once it happens but I
want to ask you about this this deal on
daca and the continuing resolution the
possibility of the government shutdown
Friday I believe it is now it do the
Democrats none of whom voted for this
tax cut do they have any leverage as it
relates to the continuing resolution and
forcing some of the issues that they'd
like to add pass they have a great deal
of explaining to do I believe as to why
none of them could admit that
individuals and employers in their
states and their congressional districts
would benefit from this it's very clear
they would so they'll have to explain
that in due course on the continuing
resolution we feel confident and we are
very hopeful that the Democrats will not
allow petty partisan politics to get in
the way of keeping our government open
and funding obligations to the military
and elsewise now on immigration people
should review the president's entire
70-point immigration plan judge Jeanine
because in it you will see everything
from daca to ending chain migration to
ending this visa lottery program to
having thousands more ice agents on the
border so that we can we can get more
security we have a 50% decrease in
illegal crossings since he was elected
we want the poison out of our out of our
country 90% of heroin the president said
comes to the southern border we have
fentanyl coming in and so all of this
adds up to a president was put forth a
70 point immigration plan including a
merit-based system and everybody should
read and not just focus on that one
component we don't have to worry that
daca is something that they can leverage
before the continuing resolution and
that the CR will pass a correct
I would hope so because the president
has made very clear that he wants that
wall funded and that that is not
negotiable and anybody who wants to
bring to the table their chief concerns
will have to will also have to hear his
due and I mean hey do we really have an
end here Kellyanne I don't mean to rush
you but won't come but do we know when
the president is going to sign this bill
sign the continuing resolution of the
the tax reform oh well there are
processes that need to impro to calls
that need to
be followed as I understand it and so
you can expect him to do that in due
course over the next couple weeks I
suppose it could happen I'm told but
today people can rest assured that that
is a formality the passage is real and
you saw a corporate America respond to
it today by passing it on unlike all the
predictions Jeanine all the breathless
predictions were corporate America would
never never allow this this tax cut to
be down to the benefit of the little guy
of the worker they were going to stick
it in their own pockets the minute it
passed before the president even went
out to the south wall and they had
already announced these bonuses they
predicted a year ago global recession
stock market crashes a disaster
everywhere the opposite has happened the
consumer confidence is historic the
unemployment rate is low the lowest ever
among Hispanics lower for
african-americans and women and teens in
a while and so all of this knitted
together shows a president and his
leadership that has been able to realize
a piece of legislation that many members
who stood behind him tomorrow had voted
on many years only to have it die on a
President's desk and some of those had
voted for the Reagan tax cuts and they
think this is even more bold well
Kellyanne we very much appreciate it
congratulations you can continue
celebrating tonight congratulations to
America thank you